pompe à l'arrêt boutiques fermées les
salariés de ces stations situe au niveau
de l'aéroport du lamentin sont en
débrayage
ils sont mécontents car la prime
exceptionnelle dite prime macron
n'auraient pas été versées à cette date
par le gérant de l'entreprise
déjà on a envoyé un courrier au départ
aux médiévales etc et de mettre en place
dès le 28 février qu'il a reçu le 28
février et après il a été relancé à
plusieurs reprises et l'a refusé tout
toutes les lignes une surprise très
désagréable pour ces automobilistes
il semble aujourd'hui s'adapter à ce
type de situation c'est de l'amour chez
les riches comme dit mme arroyo
je comprends parfaitement non pas du
tout pas du tout lalala cause elle est
légitime doc
les représentants de la section cgt m
des produits pétroliers majorité en
martinique justifient leur position par
rapport aux énormes bénéfices indus
clarté engendrés par les gérants des
stations-service
contrairement à ce que prétend des
gérants il ramasse un pactole sur le
carburant
tous les ans depuis juin 2008
il ramasse plus de 2 millions par an et
cet argent il n'en distribue absolument
pas à leurs salariés
aujourd'hui il y a c'est la date limite
pour le versement d'une prime dite
exceptionnelle et certains disent que
ils n'ont pas les moyens
nous savons qu'ils ont les moyens
rencontrer en urgence la direction et
maintenant le souhait des salariés
mais ce matin il y avait tout de même
une certaine influence dans cette
station non pas pour remplir les
réservoirs mais tout simplement pour
s'approvisionner en bout d'un local